[Music]
the bones of the earth is a short story
contained in ursula kayla green's fifth
earth sea book tales from earthsea and
it is indeed a tale about a character at
first called silence and his old teacher
and mentor
dolls it's going to turn out that
silence is in fact ogean the silent the
mage who originally took ged in taught
him sent him off to rogue welcomed him
back there's a lot more backstory there
as well in the earlier earthsea novels
but now we're getting to learn about
ogian himself and his teacher and the
teacher of his teacher as well as a
little bit about a character who appears
very early on
in wizard of earthsea and who dies as a
result of ged's foolishness and that is
the arc mage nemerle this is before he
is indeed the arc mage uh that a lot of
the things are are taking place and so
we have this character dolls we find out
his true name early on
in a kind of unusual way helleth and he
is the wizard of ray alby before ogien
will be the wizard of ray alby
and
he's kind of a you know in many respects
an ordinary guy although he is also a
man of power
he studies first on gaunt with the
wizard aard who we're going to find out
a little bit later is actually a woman
very unusual
in that she's not a witch but rather an
actual
wizard and there's there's a lot going
on there to talk about then he goes to
roque and studies in particular
with nemerle when nemerle is the
patterner who lives in the imminent
grove right before nemerle will become
the the arc mage who is
the one when when ged goes there and
then he comes back to gant and he lives
a rather
simple life we find him at the very
beginning talking about the wooden floor
that silence or ogean has put in place
he's he's not very happy about it
although he is also happy that his his
pupil did all that work for him he walks
around barefoot why does he walk around
barefoot because that's a way that he
can connect with the earth and so we see
this interesting
little vignette at the beginning when he
was a child he'd like to walk in mud he
remembered enjoying the cool of it
rising between his toes he still liked
to go barefoot but no longer enjoyed mud
it was a sticky stuff and he disliked
stooping to clean his feet before going
into the house when he'd had a dirt
floor it hadn't mattered but now he had
a wooden floor like a lord or a merchant
or an ark mage to keep the cold and damp
out of his bones
not his own notion silence had come up
from god port last spring to lay a floor
in the old house they'd had one of their
arguments about it he should have known
better after all this time then to argue
with silence and then he begins thinking
about
his time
with silence and
again great uh storytelling here
he turned up on dulce's doorstep a few
years ago well no
20 years ago it must be or 25 a while
now he'd been truly a boy then
long-legged rough-haired soft face a set
mouth clear eyes
and so this is you know going back quite
a way he's he's remembering when ogian
first came to study or ojin doesn't even
say to study he just says to learn
to learn with dolls and
it's very interesting how he winds up
getting
his name what we learned a little bit
later from dulce inquiring about it
is that silence was a town boy born in
god port he'd said nothing about himself
but dulce had asked around a bit his
father a long shoreman had died in the
big earthquake when silence would have
been seven or eight the mother was a
cook at a waterfront inn at 12 the boy
had gotten into some kind of trouble
probably messing about with magic and
the mother had managed to apprentice him
to a lawson a rep a respectable sorcerer
and valmoth
there the boy had picked up his true
name and some skill in carpentry and
farm work if not much else and alastair
had had the generosity after three years
to pay his passage to rogue that was all
that dulce knew
about him and silence isn't really
saying
anything more so we've got this back
we find out that
silence has already been to rock because
dulce is going to suggest to him well
here we go here's the the story um dulce
knew what what he wanted what they all
wanted keeping his eyes from those clear
eyes he was a good teacher
the best on gant he knew that but he was
tired of teaching
he didn't want another apprentice under
foot any sense danger
right so
sometimes the reward for being good at
what you do is people give you more and
more of it even if you don't want it and
dulse turns out to be you know quite a
good teacher in fact
he's had good teachers himself
so
odion or silence has come to him and he
says i want to learn and dull says
well go to rock
you know he says you can afford passage
and then he says i've been there
dulse looks them over again no cloak
no staff why does that matter well if he
had a staff that would be because he was
in fact a mage and had completed his
training and we'd be sent out so he asks
failed sent away run away the boy shook
his head at each question he shut his
eyes his mouth was already shut he stood
there intensely gathered suffering drew
breath looked straight into the wizard's
eye so he's not answering the questions
other than to say no no no
and then here's what he says
my mastery is here on god
my master is helleth
i said that we learn helleth or dols's
true name
ogen has his true name he probably
shouldn't
but he does
how did he get it how did he
arrive at it perhaps neverlay told him
we don't actually find out do we
but he says his mastery is at rock his
finishing as a
wizard is not or is is a gaunt rather
his his mastery is not in rock
roe can teach him a lot
but
there's something more that can be
taught to him from godish
magic
in silence dull sought the boy's name
and saw two things a fur cone in the
rune of the rose closed mouth then
seeking further he heard in his mind a
name spoken but did not speak it and
then he says to the young boy i'm tired
of teaching and talking i need silence
is that enough for you the boy not at
once then to me you are silence you can
sleep in the nook and he begins teaching
him so we have silence in a couple
different ways the young boy is being
named silence later on he will be the
silent one
he's also expected to work
in silence as much as possible not total
silence of course because teaching
cannot take place without there being
some articulation but the silence
allows them to punctuate
uh with words this this vast background
you might say
and so dolph teaches silence
and there's a really interesting phrase
here that prefigures what's going to
happen later on in the story
he's going to teach him mastery
you know teaching the high arts teaching
spells things like that but also
what went deeper
than mastery that's a good thing for us
to think about what does
go deeper
than mastery turns it into
mere
mastery that perhaps is something dulls
could teach him
what he had learned here on gant before
he ever went to
rogue
what he had learned from his own teacher
art
and what he had learned in the process
afterwards as well
and here then we get some really
interesting ruminations
by dulce about fathers and sons
he says uh
dulse thought sometimes in those years
about sons and fathers he had quarreled
with his own father a sorcerer
prospector over his own choice of art as
his teacher he his father had shouted
that a student of ards was no son of his
and nursed his rage died unforgiving
so you know we know that there's some
some bad blood perhaps professional
jealousy between his father and aard as
it's going to turn out later
it has to do with the fact that art is
actually a sorceress right a wizard
and so she doesn't have a staff by the
way either because of course she didn't
go to
gant she did study with a mage herself
as we find out
dulce had seen young men weep for joy at
the birth of a first son he'd seen poor
men pay witches a year's earnings for
the promise of a healthy boy and a rich
man touch his gold but dizzened baby's
face and whisper adoringly my
immortality now this is worth hesitating
on for a moment
it's it's often the case that parents
project into their children something
that doesn't need to be there their own
immortality their own legacy
and that's not quite allowing the child
to be
what they're going to be
he'd also he says seen men beat their
sons bully and humiliate them
spite and thwart them hating the death
they saw in them he'd seen the answering
hatred in the son's eyes the threat the
pitiless contempt and seeing it dulse
knew why he'd never sought
reconciliation with his father so this
is another model of fathers and sons a
kind of rivalry between the two of them
a hatred that that continues and then
there's a third possibility
he had seen a father and son work
together from daybreak to sundown
the old man guiding a blind ox the
middle-aged man driving the iron-bladed
plow never a word spoken
and as they started home the old man lay
his hand a moment
on the son's shoulder
a gesture of
love and companionship he'd always
remembered that he remembered it now
when he looked across the hearth winter
evenings at the dark face bent above a
lore book or a shirt that needed mending
the eyes cast down the mouth closed the
spirit
listening and this is
his silence
he sees him as something like his son
this will come up again very explicitly
in another
passage and then he tells silence about
nemerle
the man who sent silence to him
um
he says once in his lifetime if he's
lucky a wizard finds someone he can talk
to nemerle had said that to adults a
night or two before dulce left
roque a year or two before nemerle was
chosen archmage if you stayed helleth we
could talk
dulse had been unable to answer it all
for a while then stammering guilty at
his ingratitude and incredulous at his
obstinacy master i would stay but my
work is on gaunt i wish it was here with
you
and nemerle says to him it's a rare gift
to know where you need to be before
you've been to all the places you don't
need to be well send me a student now
and then
rock needs gauntish wizardry i think
we're leaving things out here things
worth knowing something very worthy of a
patterner in earthsea saying the ones
who
look to the pattern itself
and we find
that
he tells
silence about this
did he ask
why didn't you come to me first and then
go to rogue to put a polish on it and
silence says i didn't want to waste your
time
and
he asked did nemerle know you were
coming to work with me silence shook his
head if you deigned to tell him your
intentions he might have sent a message
to me silence looked stricken was he
your friend
dulse paused he was my master would have
been my friend perhaps if i'd stayed on
rock
have wizards friends no more than they
have wives or sons i suppose
once he said to me that in our trade
it's a lucky man who finds someone to
talk to
keep that in mind if you're lucky one
day you'll have to open your mouth
silence bowed his rough thoughtful head
if it hasn't rusted shut adults added if
you ask me to i'll talk the young men
said so earnest so willing to deny his
whole nature at dulce's request that the
wizard had to
laugh
and so there's this exchange and it's
you know like a fatherly son exchange
even though is being denied in the very
process and then what we find
is that
dulce has the big lore book open on the
table he had been trying to re-weave one
of the acostan spells much broken and
made powerless centuries ago he had just
begun to get a sense of the missing word
that might fill one of the gaps he
almost had it and then silence breaks
his silence you might keep some goats
and they have a discussion about goats
and things like that and then they work
together on the spell
again
so here's here's the
the
reference
after spending the next several days
trying to recapture capture the missing
word
he had set silence to studying the cost
and spells
together
they finally worked it out a long toil
like plowing with a blind ox dulse said
going back to this passage
he had seen the
father and son work together from
daybreak to sundown the old man guiding
a blind ox the middle-aged man driving
the iron-bladed plow plow
that is them
in in this image
not after not long after that he gave
silence the staff he had made for him of
gauntish oak and the lord of god port
had tried once again to get dulse to
come down to do what needed doing in
ganport and dulse had sent silence down
instead and there he had stayed his
apprenticeship is finished he has
learned what he needed to learn
from dals according to dulce and now has
his staff he has finished his education
nearly
uh
at least the education he's receiving
from other wizards including dolls and
through dulse from
ard
you